il ya une histoire qui pourrait être un
canular
est-ce de l'info est de l'intox le 7
mars 1984 le services des égouts de la
ville de paris lance un appel d'urgence
à la caserne des pompiers du 1er
arrondissement un animal suspect a été
repéré à deux reprises dans les égouts
situé sous la rue du pont neuf
il s'agit peut-être d'un crocodile
nous sommes partis après une première
recherche qui s'est révélé pratiquement
infructueux nous avons approfondi
quelque peu hélas un crocodile de 70 à
80 centimètres environ a été trouvé dans
lego nous avons pris une pelle à balai
et nous avons essayé de stopper sa
progression
ce que nous avons réussi à faire et puis
nous lui avons fille stella gueule de
façon à ce qu'il ne nous passe pas le
crocodile est aussitôt transférés à la
ménagerie du jardin des plantes pour
être examiné c'est un crocodile du nil
et il est en parfaite santé
c'est quand même assez possible du skiff
et relativement chaud dans les égouts
qui a de l'eau par définition et qui a
de la nourriture en tout cas pour des
crocodiles des proies vivantes des rats
très probablement des tas de nourriture
de viande même un peu avariée or les
prédateurs on le sait sont relativement
robuste aux infections et résistant et
donc il a très bien pu survivre un mois
un mois et demi deux mois dans les
égouts nous on l'a gardé un petit moment
ici dans cette cage là où il ya
maintenant bois et on était vite
confronté à un problème de place parce
qu'il a grandi quand même et nous avons
été obligés de le mettre en dépôt dans
un
dans une autre institution d'un aquarium
en province pour qu'ils aient une place
suffisante pour continuer de grandir
c'est à l'aquarium de vannes que nous
l'avons enfin retrouvé dans un terrarium
spécialement construit pour lui le
crocodile breton a aujourd'hui une
dizaine d'années il est en pleine
croissance et n'a toujours mangé
personne
c'est une espèce qui est agressive qui
est potentiellement dangereuse pour
l'homme c'est un animal qui dans la
nature atteint une taille de 4 à 6 m
personne ne l ayant réclamé
on pense que c'est une personne qui
devait l'avoir chez elle certainement
dans une baignoire est arrivée une
certaine taille et est venu s'en
débarrasser ce ne sont pas des animaux
de compagnie aujourd'hui notre crocodile
passe sa vie à lézarder peut être
regrette-t-il la vie trépidante du pari
underground trouver dans les égouts de
paris s de l'info est de l'intox
vous n'en savez rien jacques dutronc le
sait peut-être on les écoute à l'oreille
moi je pense que c'est tout à fait de
l'info ouais cette fois parce que
crocodile et toi moi j'ai changé a
carrément génial c'est de l'intox avant
et oui jacques dutronc lui n'y croit à
lui tu m'as dit que c'était de l'info
toi tu as eu de bons à new york ça a été
très fréquent bon paris j'en sais rien
bon ben voilà on écoute les experts
filipe vieira nord thierry on n'écoute
pas l'expert
ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'on
travaille ensemble j'ai demandé à
dominique colonna notre réalisateur de
faire un gros plan sur toi et maintenant
en ton âme et conscience
tu vas toi répondre à ce reportage c'est
de l'info ou de l'intox à ton avis j'en
sais rien anono une réponse une aurore
franchement je n'en sais rien une
réponse je crois que c'est de l'intox
quand même et bien perdu puisque c'est
totalement de l'info on applaudit
terrorisme
les corrections de ne rien rater de la
latitude
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu